or le mot dire merci en tout cas d'être
avec moi je vais faire à la nuda
allemagne on fait donc à la version
tunisienne
je le dis tout de suite il ya des
candidats ce soir ils sont tous copains
main dans la main mais bien entendu ils
ne peuvent pas se blairer qui a le
cerveau d'un moineau qui passera pour un
génie j'ai déjà ma petite idée première
manche une minute 24 mai sur essayer de
répondre chez vous et sur twitter et sur
hbo vous dites nous à votre avis qui va
gagner et je vous envoie je vous donne
un cadeau sûr et certain seuil les voilà
vous savez quoi je vous envoie ma veste
du jour voilà il faut de faire ma taille
dont j'ai rien d'autre sur moi regarder
un g3 pièces que je vais envoyer les
gens voient la baisse est pour moi
là-bas vais stopper ça ne va pas du tout
je suis dégueulasse allez donc attention
une minute vingt trois candidats seront
éliminés à l'issue de cette manche je
vous le dis tout de suite dont vous
aurez trois noms à mettre sur vos petits
sur vos petites tablettes
attention vous connaissez le principe
dès que vous voulez banque et vous
mettez de côté bien sûr l'argent
d'accord vous avez tous compris que la
table connaissez le principe
alors vous devez vous présenter donc
attention on démarre
cécile je suis animatrice je compte
prochainement remplacer doha lectra
exploratrices voilà bien très bien
valérie je suis animatrice télé est
également rédactrice en chef de brushing
magazine il appelle morini-bosc mais
l'année de la mention de la gourde il va
en est résident quelque chose
jean-michel célibataire cherche femme
pour un soir sexuelle et pour aller
boire un verre appréciable thierry
champion du monde de la blague pourrie
et pêcheurs de carpes gilles verdez
gilles dans la vie j'ai deux passions
dans l'ordre fatto et le musée du louvre
bruno chroniqueur historique de touche
pas à mon poste depuis une heure enora
égérie d'une marque de canapé bonjour
jean luc j'ai une passion dans la vie
fatou
et enfin johann j'anime intervilles sur
gulli je suis un peu le nouveau guy lux
avec cette france
je vous le dis tout de suite je sais pas
du tout où il ya ya combien par bonne
réponse s'il vous plaît combien par
bonne réponse s'il vous plaît vous
pouvez me dire en régie je crois qu'il
ya 50 euros à m a pas à chaque fois par
bonne réponse donc vous banques et à
chaque fois on va démarrer par cécile et
6,6 mettez de l'argent parce qu'en régie
me dise non mettez de l'argent je veux
donner de l'argent à une association
voilà donc vous mettez de l'argent à
chaque fois que je sais pas combien vous
mettez de l'argent ce sont aujourd'hui
chez le maire c'est quoi vous avez dit
quoi dites moi pas dit plus
sans quoi sans nom d'anciens héros pour
tous toucheront 10 600 euros par bonne
réponse c'est vachement bien qu'on
donnera aux restos du coeur donc fait
garde les chéris d'accord un répondait
bien attention c'est parti
cécile avec quelle animatrice benjamin
castaldi at il était marié
thierry flamand quelle a été la première
émission présentée par jean-luc
reichmann valérie attention à la marche
oui quel âge à bernard montiel 57 ou 62
ans 57 oui à n'oubliez pas de bloquer
quoi arrêter cette phrase oui compléter
cette phrase peine inrap tête deux
tigres oui quelle animatrice présente
toute une histoire sur france 2 thierry
sophie davant oui gilles qu'est ce qu'il
ne faut surtout pas tirer dans
l'émission motus la chasse d'eau
maîtrise
quelle sorte que ce canadienne est
devenue animatrice sur france 3 l'an
dernier et bruno roger-petit natacha
sont bien oui quel est le nom de
l'émission fitness diffusée sur des 8 et
9 ans gym direct oui quel duo a présenté
le hit machine pendant 13 ans jean luc
piens l'élu qui a incarné le lieutenant
columbo bank bank donc qu'elle a qui a
incarné le lieutenant columbo peter falk
oui vrai ou faux bernard minet hervé
mathoux ont présenté leur démission
téléachat faux faux bond quelle télé
crochet a été lancé en 2001 sur tf1 star
académie oui où a été tourné la
téléréalité nice people
mais à nice oui quel animal était
françois hollande dans le bébête show
and torture
mais lors il n'y était pas quelle chaîne
est diffusée sur le canal 11 de la tnt
ou là je ne sais pas nt1
quelle émission consacrée au football et
diffusée le dimanche matin sur tf1
gilles verdez c'est le foot
oui quelle que propose catherine ceylac
au petit déjeuner thé ou café thé ou
café thé ou café
alors ils ont mis combien aux banques
ils ont mis 550 euros c'est pas mal du
tout voici choisi orange vrai oui c'est
que je tiens quand même à surgy l'a fait
la réponse la plus con avec la chasse
d'où ils continuent à jouer quand même
mais bon sang comment tu mets ton mais
qui découvre là allez vous-en d'éliminer
trois c'est parti s'il vous plaît qui a
été le plus nul très vite s'il vous
plaît
3 oui 3 malaisie on va démarrer par
johan par johanna c'est vrai que
j'arrête pas de l'appeler yoann mais
c'est johan allez vibrer vous plaît
johann qui élimine et vous les trois
noms que vous éliminez dans ce maillon
faible
allez-y joues à ton à lévis doit
attendre je vous dis pas je me déplace à
dos allez-y donc vous éliminez jean
marie jean michel jean michel et north
america pas de jean-marie si jean michel
enault reiki brest progrès sont
l'écriture est brûlant et bruno d'accord
jean luc moi je changeais les mines jean
michel gilles et bruno et gillis s'est
pas tout seul sur photo c'est gilles
bruno et gilou bruno jean michel jean
luc et gilles très bien j'ai jean michel
isabelle et thierry thierry gilles gens
me et bruno très bien johan gélot bruno
roy avoue gilles gens me bruno brel
arabia bruno gilles et jean michel et
vous jean michel gil et jo anne laure et
bien et bien je vais vous dire j'ai fait
les comptes dans ma tête les trois
éliminés sur bruno gilles et jean michel
ce sont les trois m
renaud jean et jean michel
voici la deuxième manche on va partir de
johan attention johan ces partis sur
quelle chaîne était jean luc delarue
avant d'arriver sur france 2 canal+
oui quel présentateur de jt mesure 1 m
65 david pujadas
oui et n'aura tout le monde en parle a
connu huit ou dix saisons c'est un terme
à tout le monde en parle a connu huit ou
dix saisons tout le monde en page 8 très
bonne réponse à quelle heure commence
l'émission sept à huit vous si riner 6
heures exactement ça 18h10 c'est pas la
bonne réponse qui présentait 7 sur 7 je
re section certaines sinclair oui bah le
produit qu'ils produisaient sacrée
soirée valérie foucault non
non c'était gérard louvin compléter ses
ravages oui jean pierre c'est mon
dernier
non oui dans la chanson de vincent lagaf
qu'est ce qui est beau le live vidéo qui
délai le bidet quelle émission encore à
l'antenne est la plus vieille du paf
selon luc le jour du seigneur oui quel
jour été diffusée la méthode cauet sur
tf1 alors j'ai dit oui quel animateur
enfilé un blouson en cuir à la fin de
son émission pendant 11 ans thierry
moreau christophe hondelatte
oui isabelle quel est le chaînon de
france 3 antennes 3 c'est fr3 attention
nous en éliminer encore 3 c'est parti
très vite oui oui à les y aller vite si
hop et trouver les noms éliminer ce que
vous n'aimez pas ce et en bambou vous
avez mis en banque 950 en tout 250
attention
allez les séries vous pourrez continuer
à sur twitter nous dire qui va gagner
bien sûr à les y aller johan vous
éliminez qui sait s'il saisit et non
chez cécile chebbi et nora jean-luc il
avait un thierry et jaune très bien
johan isabelle et thierry et isabelle
valérie et cécile très bien leurs
héritiers vie cécile et johan oui moi
que les garçons thierry et jean luc jean
luc thierry et johan alors google
je suis en train de faire les comptes
dans ma tête je vous le dis tout de
suite grâce à l'oreillette que je
pensais
c'est bon c'est donc johann thierry et
yoann thierry et toi non pas possible
chez moi thuriau ranieri qui s'il vous
plaît yoann thierry et cécile et qui
sont éliminés et oui yoann thierry et
cécile apparemment je sais pas ils ont
fait les combos à mon avis à de la
magouille
ok je vous le dit johan thierry et s'il
s'estime audi attention on repart est ce
que il reste donc jean luc et nora
isabelle et valérie vous en éliminer
deux après il y aura la grande finale
jean-luc attention c'est parti c'est
avoue jean-luc top
quelle animatrice à pour geek ma chérie
et tout est magnifique
cristina cordula qui présentait égalem
si ces droits mais tu m'as tu laisses
dit oui quelle série de france 3 se
déroule à marseille même plus belle la
vie
oui valérie anc de quel sujet traite
l'émission silence ça pousse de
jardinage
oui quelle émission d'aventuré revient
prochainement sur tf1 koh lanta oui qui
présente l'émission top chef sur m6 et
noir attenberg oui donc lé ville se
déroulent les experts à manhattan
isabelle manhattan à new york douillard
elle bien ok démission at on pu voir at
on pu voir laurent ournac danseur
flamenco dans certains bars avec les
stars oui quelle chaîne a pour slogan la
petite chaîne qui monte m6
ce n'est pas montée n'est pas monté
rien n'est pas dans l'oubli ce qui nous
fait 1300 euros
1300 euros pour les restos du coeur vous
avez une idée d'un les séries de allez-y
c'est parti comme ça on aura la finale
et chez vous vous allez savoir qui va
gagner ce ballon faible attention je
rappelle que ça arrive sur des beats à
partir de 17 heures dès lundi jean-luc
vous éliminez valérie hamel et de l'udc
isabelle et jean luc isabelle jean luc
et nora jean luc et noura enfin saint
jean luc et nora berra ont été coulés
way jean luc et nous quitte
la finale oppose
il s'appelle noélie bosque et valérie
bénaïm société retient robert nous voir
on va faire une mort subite serviable et
vous vous êtes et limite la crotte
sociaux bon vous isabelle morini-bosc
compression plus quel humoriste incarner
marie besnard l'empoisonneuse dans un
téléfilm hubert robin bonnes réponses
qui a animé la nouvelle star 2007 à 2009
allait révéler de 2007 à terre-neuve
la buse est perdu
les revenus j'ai perdu mais c'est
isabelle monde
isabelle morini-bosc donc sa rivale à 10
à 17 heures
et franchement alors sur twitter on va
me dire mais je pense que la personne
qui a misé sur isabelle donc ça c'est
pas s'il a un gagnant on va voir mais à
mon avis je pense que je vais garder ma
veste merci javel en tout cas c'est jean
luc et où vous avez misé sur jean luc
legras bien sûr travailleurs réunis
autour d'une table on me spolier